you
everyone's Gerry I'm on Ches comms
tactics trainer right now and we'll try
three puzzles and just share my thoughts
along the way so compared to the last
group of three puzzles I did I'm
anticipating this one is going to be a
bit difficult my rating has increased a
little bit from the last time so let's
give these ago this is one where it's
white to move hmm all right let's see
what is my eye focused on from this
initial position well I'm looking at the
d5 square for one could take one
all guns against the Queen she's
unprotected I'm looking at g5 his tempo
gaining moves might there be something
against the king at some stage and
there's also this capture on the e5
let's see hmm what's the trick with this
one this square is guarded enough both
the bishop and the knight or controlling
g-form
hmm or is black vulnerable capture here
what are blacks replies F takes E
you
okay I'm seeing something here where on
F take see initially I thought that
maybe there's Knight takes e4 in reply
but that would be shot down with Knight
takes d5 hitting the Queen and removing
the defender of the knight on e4 so that
wouldn't be a good reply hmm an F takes
II what about D takes a this is
something I think I need to work out huh
I think I think I'm in the right I think
I'm going in the right direction here F
takes E or not F takes G Queen take C
what am i doing after that that's not so
clear I mean she's still unprotected on
the e5 square F take C Queen takes e
could attack her with like Bishop D for
Bishop g3 but I'm black isn't
necessarily having to react to a threat
thrown at the Queen because there's
always this D takes a move F takes a
queen takes e some attack against the
black queen there's D takes e hitting
the white queen first
and I thought about night a 40 v6 but
that seems way too slow and this capture
here I don't know what it even amounts
to and I takes like on this initial move
Knight takes d5 Knight takes rook takes
and black has like a free move it feels
so probably not the direction to go and
I want have to be more forceful hmm
really lacking in candidate moves for
sure here not sure what else
sitter besides F takes eg5 on g5 there's
hang out for a second hmm oh there is
something with this starting to see it
now this sneaky rook on g1 g5 on g5 d
takes e ha this is sneaky g5 d takes e
pawn takes knight oh man what a sneaky
puzzle pun takes Knight pawn takes Queen
and then Knight d5 with this pawn on f6
in the G file now half opened for white
after a queen move that would follow
Knight takes bishop with check and then
pawn takes g7 that would be main oh man
that's the solution g5 it is choppin f6
and Knight d5 what a sneaky puzzle it's
continuing that's as far as it went
but we're up a piece now so if the Queen
moved it would have been Knight takes
Bishop and pawn takes is there anything
else check King here I don't know what
the follow-up would be I think you just
cash out here grab the Queen
oh that took a bit more difficult than
the usual group of three but yeah that
final variation that I wanted to point
out here let's see if I get sighs up the
window well enough yeah this position
right here on g5 takes takes takes
Knight d5 if there's a Queen move just
say here well this is bad for multiple
recent
that just showing the mating idea you'd
have to give up the Queen here because
after this that's a cool finish mate
fork me
okay let's try puzzle two puzzle two of
three Oh my first thought is that it's
going to require a lot of calculation
okay
well mmm this feels like an in-game
study okay
these could really take forever and I'm
not going to spend forever on these so
I'm not going to spend too much time
this pawn is ready to Queen and there's
not a lot you could do to stop that from
happening
93 is not working King takes or pawn
takes so these guys are moving this way
sometimes easy to get confused with that
what else can we try we have some checks
there's a check on e5 there's a check on
a 7 hmm to be clever here where is
something clever you know this does
remind me of some in-game study nothing
in particular that I'm recalling just
generally speaking about in game studies
something where every piece and every
pawn somehow will play a role in some
way in some variations so let's see how
come my first job here I would think at
least is to stop this pawn from cleaning
it's white to move weight to move how do
you stop this pond from cleaning I don't
know
candidate moves Bishop a7 check what
does that really do Bishop hey Simon
check suppose after Bishop a7 check King
d5 now what a good answer turn now what
not at all
and that's not his only option either I
mean he could go to c3 and there's not
so much happening there either Bishop
check King c3 Knight a4 throw a check in
there King C - what are you doing next I
still don't have a good answer to that
there's no time for like Bishop g3 Queen
and some pawn push with a discovered
attack the King won't be in check after
enough pawn push is their way to force
the King somehow to the e-file so that
when this pawn moves it would be with
check hmm let's see
might it be a king move to start with
Bishop to e5
hmmm sneakiness who I really do feel
like this is an endgame studying these
are tough hmm what else to consider them
pretty much abandoning some pawn mill it
just seems to slow a 6e Queen a7 and
then black Queens gonna have a lot of
fun giving checks and everything too
slow chalk that one up is too slow so
I'm thinking it has to be a bishop move
to start or a king move
suppose King e6
what does that even do King e6 Queen
Bishop e5 check it's close to me the
close isn't good enough
queen a king east six Queen Bishop e5
check King c5 that's blacks only illegal
move there might be something to this
because now black is a bit restricted
right after King e6 after some Bishop
move hmm what about what about Bishop
check right away hang on Bishop check
right away
hmm bishop check King takes night check
mm-hmm yeah it just feels like he's
gonna have too many options maybe not
let's see Bishop check King takes Bishop
Knight c4 check where would the King go
from there let's see if we're allowed to
go to the e3 square with check then
we'll be able to stop the e2 pond by way
of c2 or g2 so after a bishop check King
takes Bishop his otherwise Bishop c3
will stop the pond Bishop checking takes
Bishop Knight c4 check oh this is it I'd
see four check and then even if the King
goes to d4 or f4 there would be 93 so
whether the king is on d4 or f4 after
black promotes there'd be if the Kings
on d4 b Knights c2 with the fork and if
the King goes to f4 be Knight g2 with
the fork I think that's it whoo okay it
is correct and then finally night here
that tricky tricky night night c2 and
that should be the end they're making
you go one more you just got to take the
Queen
oh man that took that took awhile and no
I don't think that that was an in-game
study coz mmm these these ponds would
have the king position would have been
more involved I think that probably
wasn't in game study but certainly had
to calculate that out seeing the fork
idea okay let's try one more puzzle
three of three team black
well alright how we do materialized um
we're down the exchange and upon an
exchange in a pond we could pick this
night up but my eye is not focused on
that my initial thought is focused over
here on the king he is a bit limited
after a bishop move he only has this
move here this is probably another
checkmate puzzle I think I see the
answer
mm-hmm no that's how fast initially I
was thinking a bishop move King here in
the night here with that somehow being
made but it's not or is it you know
isn't that just a meeting - is that what
this is how this is finishing a mating -
oh my goodness that's what it is
I'm eight until going from that second
puzzle to this one oh man
bishop here is a discovered check and
the King only has one legal move King to
d3 and then Knight e5 attacks the King
guards this Square and there are no
other squares for the King to go to this
is the main - oh well that wasn't the
real AHA I'm I was probably a way to end
these group of three but okay I guess
every now and then you get a checkmate
problem we didn't know that from the
beginning but uh feel free to share how
you did with these three certainly the
first two were more much more difficult
but yeah as usual feel free to share how
you did with these in the comment
section below and I'll catch you in the
next video
take care bye
you